[Applause]
happy thanksgiving theme song
um thank you you you didn't have to ride
on a float today i hope you're online oh
no thank heavens i did not but i i did
watch the floats oh yeah yeah i have uh
um i'm lucky enough to have a a window
that looks out on the park so and it's
on the fifth floor so the floats really
go by at eye level which makes them kind
of terrifying
actually i would think you're just you
wake up in the morning and what just you
know barney's looking in and here's the
here's the deal thanksgiving you have to
wake up real early to walk the dogs
because after say 7 30 you can't get by
the people so you walk the dogs you come
back in you wash the floor you have um
and then i have people with children
over
and they look out the window and they
watch the floats and and spiderman came
by and they started screaming and crying
you know and so that's well that's the
meaning that's what thanksgiving is all
about terrifying people small children
cry that's what i'm up to i like to
think that's what it's all about do you
like thanksgiving
um
the truth is
really come on what's wrong with
thanksgiving besides the terrifying
aspect of it
well this other terrifying aspect of it
for me
is i mean i don't i mean i'm i'm great
look i'm grateful like everybody is for
the for my friends and my health and my
my everything but um i don't like
gatherings of people
um
is this too much right now
this is okay what the hell am i doing
here
i don't like gatherings of people i'll
come to a taping of a talk show a large
talk show no i don't like having to go
to parties i'm not good at that and i
guess my favorite thanksgiving no
offense to my dear friend jim brooks who
has me over every year when i adore him
he's the one that wrote taxi and
everything um but my favorite one i
think a friend of mine jackie and myself
went to a coffee shop across from
lincoln center and ordered every kind of
potato that you know
well
and why not i ask you i love it it's
funny no way well what possessed you to
do that why well because that was
well there was that
and then that was exactly what we wanted
to do and we decided this one year not
to sort of give in to the pressure of oh
family and groups and friends oh you're
a lot of fun
family and groups and friends i'm sorry
but you asked me to be honest so what
did you do so the potato thing did that
work out well you just had that worked
out deliciously well i must
well we had the boiled potatoes the
fries
the baked potatoes wow the mashed
potatoes oh okay i had a side order of
applesauce myself
you had potatoes all a mode
which is very good but um but i do have
also a lovely time at jim brooks's house
because um he's my friend since taxi
produced taxi and taxi by the way is is
running right now
it's everywhere it's a great show i'm a
it's nice
one of the great things about uh nick
lauren they bring these shows back and
and and you on taxi uh i've always i
like to to talk about uh andy kaufman or
ask about him anyway he played latke on
the show yeah and uh i just you know
he's a big comedy hero of mine and i'm
curious what was it like working with
him i know he worked very closely with
him on the show
um it was it was peculiar
and um and um oh there he is
well
and and magnificent because he's a
genius you know so so of course it would
be peculiar because he's it's not the
norm it was so special and what kind of
things would he do when you're working
with him you must have had to rehearse
with him well yes i think or one of the
interesting things
that i had occasion to do with him was
um learn the language remember like lika
had this special language and so i said
to andy you know i'm just i'm very
nervous about learning this language and
he said don't be silly it's all you do
is you just open it's like when little
kids
think they speak russian or french you
just open your mouth and start talking
you know so all very well for andy you
know who had invented it but it had a
very specific rhythm and there were
actually certain words that meant things
yeah like yak debay meant
rear end
yakta bay yeah oh and eb diamond yes
there were a few words that well you
know that don't you be dummies yes
what do you think i've studied all
languages but so he um i i'm kind of a
method actress and i and i said to him
please you have to help me feel
comfortable in the language so he said
okay fine we will go
my plan is we'll go to a restaurant
where nobody knows either of us and we
will speak only in that language and so
in order to do that i thought what we
would do is we would go to mexico
and he told me this at six o'clock the
friday evening we were having dinner
we're going to mexico so i thought oh my
god but you know i really i really want
to do a good job so i'll try and be
flexible and then he gets on the phone
he starts talking to people and time's
going by and i finally said andy you
know if we're going to go to mexico
tonight
don't you think
and he looked at me like i was
completely out of my mind
out of my mind see that was one of the
interesting things about andy's he
couldn't believe that you believed him
that you were actually going but then uh
on the other hand a lot of times he um
would say something that you knew wasn't
true and he could not believe that you
would not believe him always faking you
out until always because he was so
committed he would never
he would never break character when he
made a decision about something that was
it